les voitures elles ne sont plus les
bienvenues devant certaines écoles
tourangelle depuis aujourd'hui la mairie
leur interdit de circuler dans les rues
de cinq établissements aux heures
d'entrée et de sortie des enfants
objectif limiter les risques d'accidents
et la pollution
si l'expérience est concluante elle
pourrait être étendue à d'autres écoles
hélène chapelet 8h10 ce matin aux abords
de l'école clocheville à tours
la circulation des voitures devant
l'établissement scolaire vient d'être
fermées temporairement plus aucun
véhicule ne passe devant l'entrée de
l'école
collinet et sa maman qui habite l'avenue
de grammont sont venus à vélo temps de
parcours 5 minutes
alors qu'en voiture elle aurait mis plus
de temps on avait un petit peu peur
d'être bloqué de du coup il faisait beau
on a pris les vélos pour le plus grand
plaisir de collins était très vieille
c'était plus agréable la voiture on
touche cinq établissements scolaires
tourangeaux sont concernés par cette
mesure
jusqu'au 18 décembre aux horaires des
entrées sorties d'école la circulation
automobile sera interdite devant les
classes un test voulue par la
municipalité qui vise à mieux sécuriser
les abords des écoles mais aussi à
réduire la pollution aux alentours le
souci c'est qu'il ya énormément de
voitures qui circulent bon alors
maintenant plus on est obligé d'ouvrir
les fenêtres tous les matins on faisait
déjà avant de toute façon le covin donc
la pollution entre dans les classes et
ça m'est très longtemps à sortir et dans
la cour de récréation aussi donc nous
c'était un double problème c'est un
problème de pollution est un problème de
circulation avec danger pour les vélos
pour les piétons bonne idée pour éviter
un peu l'embouteillage du quartier le
matin
mauvaise idée pour ceux qui viennent
peut-être un peu de loin et qui ont du
mal aussi les gestes gare aux abords on
m'explique confère une rue mais l'école
est un angle donc si on veut vraiment
être dans l'efficacité faut que les
voitures ne passe nulle part sinon les
voitures vont prendre un autre chemin
al'approche de l'été prendre son vélo ou
marche est un peu pour se rendre à
l'école devrait faire quelques adeptes
cet hiver ce sera peut-être moins
évident dans tous les cas un premier
bilan de cette expérimentation devrait
être fait à la fin de l'année scolaire